tombé ce n'est pas de voir un enfant
heureux avec deux personnes du même sexe
que un enfant malheureux peut-être avec
depuis l'entrée il ya des langues et des
comme ça qu'ils vont mal partout alors
bah oui
alors
vous savez ce qu'il m'a dit je suis
contre le mariage parce que y'a la
filiation gnagnan enlever la filiation
parce que si on disait ok la gpa les pma
c'est interdit aux homosexuels est
uniquement le mariage autorisé mais
madame serait bien mal parce que elle
est contre le mariage tout court entre
deux hommes ou entre les femmes et les
enfants l'enfance est une excuse de lomé
madame maison concernant les moins de
sérénité
ça
et des enfants des andes pour masquer
notre moto vie certes ou madame c'est
toi c'est ça c'est quand on veut faire
la victime est alors on le
sait la force des grandes classiques
soyons très clairs une union avec un
couple de même sexe un couple homosexuel
qui étaient unis ne me pose aucun
problème
le mariage c'est simplement la filiation
il ya une filiation possible en dehors
du mariage mais si vous avez déjà été un
mariage à la mairie qu'est-ce qu'on
parle on lit les articles du code civil
qui parle des enfants à venir et tout le
sujet est là mais c'est vous qui est
sexiste d'un canton se marier comme une
femme c'est forcément pour pondre c'est
pour faire des enfants n'a pas forcément
posée alors il est pas ce qu on veut se
marier pas c'est quoi sinon ce que vous
dites mais le maquillage fouquet's et le
texte n'a rien dit alors à des enfants
et de ce que vous dites le mariage m
entraîne la filiation il n'y a pas
révélé ses prix hommage un boulot comme
ça je peux pas vous voir dans plein de
manière générale et on a généralisé non
dans le mag dont la loi le mariage à 100
vous voyez bien que c'est une bouteille
le mariage des personnes de même sexe on
vient d'avoir la légalisation de la pma
son père est encore une forme va priver
pour toujours faire volontairement des
enfants orphelins de père et on a déjà
la revendication des mères porteuses qui
est sur la table des femmes qu'on va
réduire à lutter à leur rupture est ce
qu'on va louer et une fois la fin d'un
gros seins sont les a sélectionnés sur
catalogue et hydra et à la fin de la
grossesse on vient prendre leur envol
contre une rémunération mais ses mots
le moi je peux entendre et non celles à
suivre c'est très bon
vous ne concevez pas comment un enfant
peut pas le fruit de deux personnes de
même sexe à la limite mais votre
discours c'est un discours de génétique
presque c'est un homme une femme mais on
est en 2021 madame je comprends pas ce
qu'ils peuvent moi j'ai des enfants j'en
ai 4 j'aurais pas pu avoir d'enfants je
redonnerai fait d'une autre façon ce qui
compte pour un enfant c'est pas d'où ils
viennent c'est comment ils sont voulus
et pasqua est vous dire une chose et moi
j'ai plein d'amis aidé à mieux qu' on
commet qui ont fait des enfants qui ont
décidé d'avoir un enfant pierre que la
volonté farouche d'avoir un enfant de
ces deux là elle vaut bien celle de deux
hommes et une femme ce qui compte pour
un enfant et j'en ai quatre c'est pas
d'où viennent ces leur amour et l'amour
qu'on leur donne est votre définition
de secours il est rétrograde et je suis
désolé je revends mon camarade de l'emmo
vous avez un discours excusez moi qui
encourage une seule chose dans ce pays
dont on n'a pas besoin l'homophobie
est bien sûr madame à ses côtés ce qui
vous dérange c'est ça il ya que ça de
noix comme la pma son père qui prive des
enfants père ne sera jamais une loi
d'amour et quand on démarre le look de
visualiser la chose les raisons sont des
éléments de langage accès léman bidon
l'amour ça c'est sûr que les céréales
amour la religion par
un jury c'est monsieur tu parle de
religion vous avez dit leur relation
d'amour je vais parler de religion la
religion sur mes relations d'amour une
loi qui prive volontairement des enfants
d'amour ne sera de père ne sera jamais
une loi d'amener m'attendais déjà été de
dire qu'à voir ces morts dedans se marie
c'est pour avoir des enfants hétéro ou
homo arrêté vers l'euro d'une femme
c'est pas forcément d'avoir un enfant
c'est pas de mettre bas fait pas une
vache
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes favorable la gpa dans la gpa
on prend les ovocytes une femme qu'on a
choisis sur catalogue on prélève contre
rémunération les les ovocytes ces deux
prélèvements ces deux scènes de la deûle
à l'exploitation reproductive on les a
et on a ces mines une femme on utilise
comme une incubatrice bon ça commence à
main on y donne des contrats incroyable
[Applaudissements]
mais sans déconner c'est son épouse
attendait c'est facile de finir à bah
oui mais bon mieux maintenant cette
amatrice